it's starting to heat up that man mmm  well we do smell delicious the smell of  death Prabhat I'm afraid yes this is our  last meal Batman then this is one time I  would advocate starting with dessert  mm-hmm I suppose it doesn't matter if we  ruin our appetites now no Robin dessert  is a new Batman film holy spoiler alert  starring us correct Robin we're back  this fall at an all-new feature-length  animated movie Batman return of the  caped crusaders holy entree Batman what  foes do we face Joker Riddler penguin  and Catwoman on earth and in space Wow  with the voices of Adam West Burt Ward  and Julie Newmar  true and a good crime fighter always  keeps his fans informed stay tuned  citizens to the Batmobile  [Music]  you